should this be the last season of Cobra
Kai what's up guys I'm back talking
about the entire fifth season of Cobra
Kai I watched it recently hear my
thoughts of minor spoilers but of course
you've already seen the trailers you
already know who the cast list is you
know who's going to be in the show let's
get down to it season four ended off
with Miguel running away from the all
Valley tournament to go find his father
in Mexico I was pumped for that
storyline I thought it was gonna add a
very different Dynamic to the show which
it desperately needs unfortunately that
storyline was very short-lived a few
episodes and we're back in the valley
and that's unfortunate because there was
a lot that the writers could really dig
into that you know Johnny's involved and
and Robbie's involved and I thought this
would be fantastic maybe it's due to
covet maybe it's due to budget maybe
it's due to Logistics I don't know but
it just really just kind of a that's it
that's all we got okay I guess we're
back in the valley again and you can
tell this show is on a very tight budget
I mean there's very few sets in this
show I mean when they do them up they're
quite nice but there's very few
locations and you kind of feel like the
first few seasons they've only put a lot
of money into this and as it goes on and
goes on they're just kind of weaning
down that budget and just trying to
maximize on Nostalgia and I feel like
that's a lot of what season five is
about Terry silver is back as the big
bad Thomas Ian Griffin does a fantastic
job he brings it up a notch Greece is in
jail we are in this element where Cobra
Kai is growing at a very fast pace it's
becoming like the nightclub of dojos
it's you know what Terry silver always
imagined it to be but you're seeing a
lot of that as it happens in every
season people on COBRA Kai not sure if
they believe in this or not you've got
Tori who's unsure of her win she finds
out that it's not what it was she
thought it was there's a lot of this
back and forth with her and Robbie yeah
the team drama is there and it just kind
of goes in a circle like a hamster in a
circle it's just over and over and over
again and if you've seen season three
season four it's the same thing in
season five now I will say this in terms
of Miguel and Samantha there's better
chemistry in season five than season
four because I thought that chemistry
was really dry back then it's gotten
better there's some elements to the
storyline which I really appreciated but
again I felt like some of the actors
were just phoning in the performances
you can see in some episodes that they
were giving it their all and some others
they were just saying lines and that's
how it kind of felt throughout season
five it was a really up and down season
for me in terms of that the star for me
this season is chosen played by
yujiokomoto he was fantastic he's like
the muscle of the uh Miyagi dough Eagle
Fang group you know it's just he's funny
he's hilarious he's got a great
storyline a great Arc I really enjoyed
what he brought to the table if there is
a season six I do hope he comes back
because he's just he's great and it adds
a nice LM because you're missing that
that what Miyagi brought to the series
that traditional Japanese culture and he
brings that into it which this show
needs to keep itself balanced because
Daniel he's great but you need that and
chosen is sort of that miyagi-ish
character in season five and I really
really liked it outside of that though
Johnny he's got some growth in this I
have to say there's a really nice change
in Johnny this season which is nice you
expect it after five seasons I'm glad
they're doing it and William zapka just
brings it and you can see he's really
embracing this role you know Ralph
Macho's Daniela Russo it's all the same
old same old same old I hope they do
something different with this character
they do a season six because it's
getting really repetitive and this is
sad for me to say because I've been a
big fan of this series thus far but I
feel like it's just not
it's not what it used to be now of
course you know Mike Barnes the bad boy
karate is back in this and I was so
pumped to see him in this man I was like
yes I can't wait to see what he does
he's gonna kick some major ass and I
don't know if it was scheduling if it
was budget or was Oprah was Logistics
but the writers didn't do crap with him
I'm like that's all you guys brought to
the table after everything you've done
with all these great characters these
you know these cameos coming into play
that's what you do with Mike Barnes ah
man I was a little bit disheartened by
that but maybe he'll come back in season
six if there is one who knows there's
also another cameo in uh this season
which I think a lot of you will like no
it's not Hilary Swank if you're
wondering that's a spoiler for you there
is no Hillary Swank in this season
whatsoever but there's another one from
Karate Kid 3 that I think you'll really
really enjoy and it ties in nicely to uh
Daniel larusso's storyline overall
though I feel like this season's been
much of the same I mean the end fight
was awesome it was violent it was great
it was pretty much I think the best
fighting we've seen in Cobra Kai thus
far but it just feels a little bit
repetitive and at the end of the series
at season five I'll be happy with it but
of course if there is a season six I'll
be the first to watch anyway those are
my thoughts on COBRA Kai let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below if you like this review check out
more of our videos right here
[Music]